[Musique]
à l'extrême sud de la Bretagne entre la
cité médiévale de Guérande et la
presqu'île du Croisic s'étendent sur
près de 1600 hectares les marais salants
les plus septentrionaux d'Europe
[Musique]
un paysage qui s'est dessiné sur une
terre de vase et dont les courbes et les
formes géométriques nous raconte une
histoire longue de plus de 1000 ans
[Musique]
histoire commence dans ce petit golfe
maritime découvert puis recouverts au
gré des marées et dont le sel va faire
la richesse
[Musique]
celle de la cité de Guérande qui dès le
Moyen-âge va organiser le négoce de ce
bien précieux
[Musique]
celle des villages alentours où les
paludiers se font construire de solides
demeure et les grandes heures de la
pêche à la morue et aux harengs qui
feront du Croisic un port international
on nomme ces deux bras de mer qui
entrent dans les terres les traits du
Croisic
c'est cette particularité géographique
originelle qui a permis d'édifier les
marais salants
nous sommes à la porte de l'océan
Atlantique à l'entrée des marais là où
terre et mer fusionnent
et lorsque la mer se retire on peut
contempler les mêmes prairies que les
premiers hommes qui peut plaire ce
territoire dès l'âge de fer
on parle de prairie maritime Airbus
laquelle était également sillonnée d'un
réseau de Chelon de marée plus ou moins
large plus ou moins profond dans
lesquels la marée s'engouffrait et
dessinait finalement des chéneaux et
tout un réseau hydraulique complexe et
c'est là dessus que les hommes ont
implanté des marais salants
[Musique]
comme si en creusant ces chaînes au
naturel la mer avait conduit les hommes
à cette pépite salée qui porte en elle
toute la richesse minérale des océans
des hommes que l'on appelle ici des
paludiers un mot issu du latin qui
signifie marais
[Musique]
à la fin du Moyen-âge les techniques de
récolte hérité des Gaulois et des
Romains sont fixés
les hommes ont appris à faire du vent et
du soleil leurs outils
[Musique]
quand il y a pas de pollution sonore
le son il vient de la mer on entend
autant de loin la mer qui est pas très
loin qui est un kilomètre
et donc ça veut dire que le vent va
venir plus de la mer pour l'instant il
n'est pas encore il va y venir parce que
ça c'est une chose qu'on improvite le
son précède pour la provenance du vent
là on sent le vent un peu à l'ouest là
et il va on entend plus ce sud-ouest
héritier d'un savoir-faire ancestral les
paludiers du 21e siècle récoltent le sel
comme le faisait leur lointains ancêtres
en utilisant l'évaporation naturelle
l'eau circule doucement dans les
méandres des Salines en pente douce pour
arriver en fin de parcours à une telle
concentration en sel qu'il cristallise
l'homme fait le reste adaptant son
travail aux différentes saisons et à la
météo
on doit récolter ici est très changeante
on est dans le sud de la Bretagne et on
est sur l'Auditorat donc cette proximité
de la terre et de la mer ça donne une
météo très particulière
donc pour apprendre pour bien régler
l'eau il faut d'abord comprendre ce qui
se passe dans la météo hyper locale on
n'est pas n'importe où on est dans une
zone avec une évaporation importante et
avec du vent qui change souvent de sens
pour pouvoir faire des réglages bataille
soir il faut anticiper le temps qui va
faire pendant la nuit ou pendant la
journée
et le plaisir qu'on a par exemple dans
des saisons ou on travaille depuis un
mois deux mois sans arrêt parce que le
temps était bon a pu travailler et puis
qu'on entend la pluie la nuit
demain repos et ces jours là sont bien
plus goûtés que les repos organisés
chaque samedi dimanche etc c'est
vraiment une autre relation avec la
nature quand on l'accepte et qu'on la
vit bien mais c'est vrai une vraie
source de bonheur
[Musique]
ce sel qui contient toute la richesse
minérale de la mer et jalousement gardé
par les remparts de la cité médiévale de
Guérande l'une des mieux conservées de
France avec ses remparts de granit qui
lui ont permis de résister aux assauts
du temps
[Musique]
si tes chéries des Ducs de Bretagne à
une époque où cette région n'est pas
encore rattachée à la France elle fut
érigée en 1450
Jean de Monfort seigneur du lieu comment
de la construction des remparts
Guérande n'est alors qu'une simple ville
marchande et religieuses
il entend ainsi un soir sa suprématie
sur le roi il veut surtout défendre la
richesse qui s'étend au pied de cette
forteresse
[Musique]
Guérande sera longtemps le pôle
économique principal de la région à une
époque où le sel constitue un véritable
or blanc
pendant des siècles il est le seul moyen
pour conserver les aliments
ceux qui le possèdent disposent alors
d'un pouvoir politique et économique
considérable
cette société du marais salants elle est
structurée entre propriétaire du foncier
qui sont alors qu'ils n'ont pas toujours
été des mêmes bien entendu mais il y a
eu à une époque le clergé il y a eu la
noblesse qui par leurs alliances par
leur stratégie matrimoniale par leur
fortune et bien finalement vont
s'arranger le sol
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Guérande est encore une cité
commerçante dont le bâti est resté
intact et où il fait bon flâner
mais c'est en s'écartant des rues
principales que l'on peut deviner
l'opulence de ceux qui possédaient le
sel
les propriétaires de salines avaient les
moyens de se faire construire bien à
l'abri des regards des manoirs
[Musique]
les paludiers eux n'habitaient pas dans
la cité
ils vivaient et vivent aujourd'hui
encore au cœur des maréchalants dans des
bourgs comme ça y est un village édifié
a même le granite où ces vieilles
pierres nous racontent le mode de vie de
ce qui fut longtemps une aristocratie
paysanne
les paludiers étaient des métayés et
avaient le droit de garder pour eux un
quart de leur production
un salaire qui vient nous rappeler
l'étymologie de ce vocable qui provient
du mot sel
d'abord il gagne de l'argent quand ils
ont vendu leurs selles il y avait
notamment la troc qui va se développer à
partir du Moyen-Âge c'est à dire que les
paludier pouvait échanger du sel contre
des biens soit manufacturés ou des
céréales donc il faisait la troc avec
leur mule il partait à travers toute la
Bretagne il revenait chargé donc de bien
échanger contre le sel la première
activité c'était le troc après il
pouvait travailler avec des négociants
pour vendre leur salle mais c'était
essentiellement quand même la troque
pendant des siècles
[Musique]
un troc lucratif comme en témoigne les
toits d'ardoise signes de richesse à une
époque où le toit de chaume était celui
du peuple
sans parler de leur beau costumes qu'ils
étaient fiers de porter
la récolte du sel n'ayant lieu que l'été
l'hiver est consacré aux travaux
d'entretien des Salines qui eux ne
rapportent rien
les paludiers développent d'autres
ressources pour vivre pendant la saison
froide
on est sur un îlot donc au sommet de cet
îlot donc les maisons sont bâties sur la
roche et en prolongement de ces
bâtiments de cette organisation vont
retrouver des terrains en lanières
chaque maison avait son terrain donc
comme des bandes on retrouve ça embrayé
aussi et c'est très typique du système
des îles en bretonne en général et là ça
va être un peu l'économie de subsistance
parce que ils vont pouvoir cultiver un
petit vélo peint de terre et en même
temps avoir peut-être des fois une vache
quelquefois un cochon vous voyez un peu
de bétail mais bon c'est toujours
peu mais ça va permettre de subvenir aux
besoins et tenir l'hiver
[Musique]
c'est au début du XVIIe siècle que les
paludiers vivent leur âge d'or grâce au
développement des grandes pêches à la
morue et aux harengs réalisés en haute
mer elle dure de longs mois et nécessite
d'énormes quantités de sel pour
conserver le poisson
[Musique]
hors de croisique port marchand à
l'époque à quelques kilomètres de
Guérande que toute l'Europe vient
s'approvisionner en sel
notamment les pays du Nord où il fait
défaut car les mers nordiques sont
beaucoup moins salées que l'Atlantique
un commerce qui va donner son visage à
la ville
toute l'histoire du Croisic est
constituée par ce commerce du sel
puisque en fait la ville a été façonnée
par les délaissages que les bateaux
marchands ont apporté en fait les
bateaux étaient des bateaux de charge en
fait des bateaux de marchandises sur le
modèle des bateaux hollandais qu'on
connaît encore aujourd'hui c'était très
large et très peu profond donc n'est pas
de quilles donc pour être stable en
haute mer il devait être lesté de
gravats de cailloux en front de cale et
donc d'où ce phénomène du lestage et du
délestage puisqu'il fallait faire de la
place quand on arrivait au Croisic pour
prendre le sel ou enlever les
marchandises qu'ils avaient dans leur
calme pour de nouveaux échanges
c'est Pierre serviront à construire les
900 mètres de quai du port qui existe
encore aujourd'hui
[Musique]
mais ces bateaux étrangers n'apportent
pas que des cailloux
il transporte parfois du bois du charbon
et d'autres matériaux avec lesquels les
riches armateurs construisent ces belles
demeures dont on peut encore admirer les
façades aujourd'hui
commerçant dans l'âme les croisicais se
chargent aussi de revendre ses denrées
étrangères dans toute la Bretagne
ici c'est un port de grossistes en fait
et
ce qui témoigne de tout ce dynamisme
c'est qu'il y avait par exemple des
interprètes de langues étrangères ici on
a eu des consulats ici consultent de
Suède consulte de Norvège conçu des
États-Unis parce qu'il y avait un tel
trafic que il y avait des échanges
privilégiés avec tous ces pays et il
fallait des interlocuteurs qui parlent
la langue ou qui puisse commercer
[Musique]
sur les chalutiers des congélateurs ont
remplacé le sel et ce dernier a cessé
depuis longtemps d'être un instrument de
pouvoir
mais aguerrande la nature et les
savoir-faire ancestraux produisent un
des selles les plus recherchés au monde
qui se vend à prix d'or blanc
[Musique]
elle surgissent comme des sentinelles de
la terre vallonnée de Franche-Comté
[Musique]
une forteresse qui surveille les
paysages une
usine dont les cheminées rejoignent le
ciel une cité industrielle aux allures
de palais royal quintessence du génie
architectural du siècle des Lumières
ces édifices ont tous été imaginés pour
extraire et sublimer une denrée
précieuse le sel franc-comtois celui de
la ville de Salins-les-Bains en
particulier
était très réputée par sa pureté sa
blancheur immaculée ce qu'on appelle
l'or blanc de salle
la Franche-Comté est une région enclavée
dans les terres éloignée de la mer et de
ses marais salants
alors que le sel était l'un des seuls
moyens de conserver les aliments sa
présence dans ses sous-sols a constituer
pendant plus de 1000 ans une fabuleuse
aubaine économique mais pas seulement en
faisant surgir parmi ces colis et ses
vallées de nouvelles formes
d'architecture et d'organisation du
travail le sel franc-comtois a propulsé
le royaume de France dans l'air
pré-industriel
c'est dans les plissures du massif
jurassien que l'histoire du sel
franc-comtois trouve sa source
là où la mer recouvrait le territoire à
l’air secondaire là où les hommes en ont
trouvé la mémoire quelques 215 millions
d'années plus tard
[Musique]
er qui amenaient des animaux aux estimes
ici ce sont rendus compte que les
maîtres descendaient toujours dans les
sources plus basses pour aller
s'abreuver et ils ont cherché à
comprendre pourquoi et se rend compte
que l'eau était plus salée donc
automatiquement ça a géré dans l'idée
des gens en disant mais le sol doit être
salé
quand l'eau s'infiltre profondément dans
l'écorce terrestres le long de la vallée
de la furieuse elle se gorge du sel
contenu dans la roche
l'exploitation de cet or blanc fait
naître ici une ville entière salin
[Musique]
elle doit son nom à l'eau salée contenue
dans son sous-sol grâce à laquelle le
bourg prospère à partir du Moyen-Âge
au 13e siècle le seigneur de ces terres
Jean de Chalon de la grande dynastie des
Princes d'Orange sa vise en effet de
donner un nouvel élan à la production du
sel
il remplace les puits traditionnels par
une imposante manufacture plongeant dans
les profondeurs de la terre
[Musique]
plus on descend ici nous sommes à peu
près à 20 mètres sous terre plus le lot
est chargé en sel
l'eau salée doit être remontée à la
surface pour cela on a imaginé ce
mécanisme d'une roue hydraulique
actionnée par la furieuse le torrent qui
traverse la ville de Sala
[Musique]
durant plus de deux siècles pas moins de
1000 ouvriers dont un quart de femme
s'activent quotidiennement sous les
voûtes de cette cathédrale industrielle
[Musique]
on produit du sel toute l'année 24
heures sur 24 jours et nuit alors de
toute façon ici nous sommes en sous-sol
donc même dans la journée il y a pas
d'éclairage et il faut utiliser des
chandelles de Suisse ça sent très
mauvais le froid l'extrême humidité la
corrosion du sel etc c'est évidemment
une vie très pénible pour ceux qui
travaillent en sous-sol
[Musique]
au niveau supérieur au milieu des nuées
brûlantes de la salle d'évaporation les
conditions de travail ne sont guère plus
enviable
[Musique]
l'eau a été remontée à la surface pour
être transmises dans des grandes cuves
que l'on fait chauffer pour procéder à
l'évaporation de la Muire de l'eau salée
afin de récolter le sel sous les taux
l'ondulés il y avait le chauffage donc
on fait chauffer cette mure et ensuite
les ouvriers les ouvrières vont
récupérer le sel et le sortir de la
chaudière
quel qu'en soit le prix l'extraction de
l'or blanc reste vital pour qui domine
la Franche-Comté
la puissante famille des apps pourvient
à l'arracher au duc de Bourgogne à la
fin du 15e siècle
mais sur son flanc ouest c'est la France
qui alors
après de veines tentatives menées par
Henri IV Louis XIV parvient finalement à
mettre la main sur ce butin
en 1674 en quelques mois le Roi Soleil
prend possession de la Franche-Comté qui
devient française
[Musique]
signe de son triomphe le Fort
Saint-André
conçu par l'ingénieur Vauban trône à 600
mètres d'altitude au-dessus de
Salins-les-Bains et veille sur le trafic
du sel qui grouille à ses pieds
il faut imaginer des milliers de
chariots qui apportent du bois pour
faire chauffer les chaudières et puis
des milliers de chariots arrivent aussi
pour prendre livraison du sel alors
comme la ville vous le voyez est une
ville rue tout en longueur évidemment ça
provoque des embouteillages monstres et
on a des témoignages de Chartier qui se
plaignent d'avoir attendu plus d'une
semaine avant de pouvoir entrer dans la
ville fortifiée pour effectuer leur
livraison
depuis Salins-les-Bains le sel inonde
les territoires alentours jusqu'au
canton suisse où il constitue une
singulière monnaie d'échange
en fournissant les élevettes à bas prix
Louis XIV obtient en contrepartie des
armées entières de soldation
le sel franc-comtois se révèle moins
cher en Suisse qu'en France où il est
lourdement taxé et fait l'objet dès lors
de tout un trafic de contrebande
on se trouve juste au bord de la vallée
du Doubs donc entre la France de ce
côté-ci est la Suisse de ce côté-là
les randonneurs qui parcourent
aujourd'hui la vallée ne se doute pas
qu'ils empruntent les chemins de
traverse tracés il y a 300 ans par les
contrebandiers du sel
aujourd'hui les échelles sont
métalliques la voiture était le cas
c'était simple de simples traverses de
bois traversé par des barraudages et
après surtout les espacités pas fixées
et comme ça les contrebandiers pouvaient
les dissimuler au pied de falaise ou
sous la broussaille ni vu ni connu
à flanc de parois des statues de la
Vierge jalonnent la falaise Clémence
Madone qui observe la Suisse éveille sur
les voyageurs
périlleux donc quand le passage était
libre il posait soit un caillou soit une
bougie et ça permettait de dire au
suivant que le passage était libre que
le doyen n'était pas présent mais
pendant ce temps à Salins-les-Bains la
manne du sel franc-comtois menace de
s'épuiser car pour approvisionner les
chaudières des forêts entières ont été
décimées et le bois vient à manquer
[Musique]
c'est à Louis XV que revient la charge
de sauver l'industrie saline de
Franche-Comté
[Musique]
au 1771 il en confie la mission au plus
grand architecte du moment Claude
Nicolas Ledoux
[Musique]
celui-ci imagine une nouvelle saline à
ses proches de la forêt de Chaux pour ne
jamais manquer de bois mais éloigné des
sources d'eau salée
[Musique]
qu'à cela tienne décidé à acheminer
l'eau depuis Salins il lance des travaux
pharaoniques pour creuser une conduite
souterraine appelée somoduc
[Musique]
la création du sommoduc a demandé les
moyens considérables réaliser cette
canalisation le long de deux rivières
avec 15000 pièces de bois 4 ans et demi
de travail pour finalement comme
l'écrire à Ledoux préféré voiture et
l'eau jusqu'à la forêt plutôt que
d'avoir un voiture et la forêt jusqu'à
l'eau était un véritable défi technique
l'eau salée est ainsi conduite sur plus
de 20 km au fil d'une canalisation dont
le dernier tronçon n'existe plus mais
qui à l'époque aboutit à sa destination
finale la manufacture de celle d'Arc et
Senan époustouflante ensemble d'édifices
qui surgit au milieu des plaines avec la
majesté d'une cité impériale ou plutôt
une cité utopique
pour concevoir sa saline Claude Nicolas
Ledoux a modelé l'espace naturel en une
vision idéale à la géométrie ciselée où
le rond et le carré se répondent dans
une parfaite harmonie
[Musique]
donc la Saline a été conçue sous la
forme d'un cadran solaire pour à la fois
symboliser la journée de travail de
l'ouvrier et en même temps le
cheminement de l'homme vers la
perfection
l'agencement des bâtiments et leur
esthétique néoclassique reflète
fidèlement cette société parfaite dans
laquelle l'homme doit s'inscrire une
société où sont rassemblés sur un même
espace les lieux de travail c'est-à-dire
les manufactures où l'on extrait le sel
et les lieux de vie des ouvriers
établis sur le demi-cercle
une société rigoureusement ordonnée et
résolument hiérarchisé ou l'ouvrier
reste subordonnée à l'autorité par le
corps comme par l'esprit
là on se trouve dans la les centrale qui
nous mène à la maison du directeur il
surplombe l'ensemble de la Saline avec
ses colonnes monumentales c'est un
bâtiment qui rassemble tous les pouvoirs
du lieu qu'ils soient politiques
administratif ou religieux on y trouvait
même une chapelle
en cette fin du XVIIIe siècle pourtant
la cité idéale de Ledoux est aussi
l'enfant des philosophes de Rousseaux en
particulier qui prônent le retour de
l'homme à la nature
nous nous trouvons dans l'un des 10
jardins de la Saline que le Doubs avait
imaginé adossé à ces maisons ouvrières
afin que chaque famille puisse disposer
d'un potager le doux était convaincu que
les villes seraient trop polluées par
l'industrie qui se développait alors et
qu'il fallait absolument allouer des
espaces verts aux populations qui
travaillaient pour cette industrie
le doux va illustrer l'essor de la
pensée au siècle des Lumières grâce à
une architecture très lumineuse et une
architecture salubre qui vise à un
progrès social
à travers la Manufacture Royale Claude
Nicolas Ledoux se révèle un précurseur
de génie en alliant lieu de travail et
lieu de vie avec la productivité comme
fin ultime il anticipe la révolution
industrielle en s'attachant au bien-être
des travailleurs il pressant la pensée
socialiste et les cités ouvrières du 19e
siècle
[Musique]